[Music]
ladies and gentlemen of the
jury how y'all doing for all of y'all
that don't know who I am my name is
Willie Gary willly Gary Wily Gary
William Gary never heard of him what's
so special about this guy
anyway litigation is war it's a battle
bam and I'm not talking about no
either I'm talking about some
Jean CLA vanam ass kicking truth is
I may have got myself into a lot of
trouble I've been your lawyer 30 years
years we can find a way out of it you've
never sued anybody before in your whole
life this tried to bully me out of
business and I don't think I should be
expected to stand for what Mr Gary
hasn't lost a case in over 12 years you
suggesting I hire this guy as one of my
lawyers y'all come on in pleasure to
meet you Mr Gary let me introduce you to
my call how do you feel about working
with black folk I suppose I am a little
Prejudice did you meet my te I'm Chris
the where douas gentlemen he's suing us
he's suing us me are are a half a
billion dollar Corporation so how much
money y'all trying to get 8 million that
ain't enough money $100
million who is this clown he's hired as
a
lawyer you're fighter man what made you
want to do it cuz he tried to mess with
one thing that means the most to me in
life being able to leave something
behind for my
grandchildren let's play some
music my name is main DS graduated top
of her class from Harvard Law School
they had a nickname for her around the
office the python I wouldn't get too
used to me being kind to you Mr Gary
once we begin that
trial I'm going destroy
you we don't have a snowballs chance in
hell winning this case just just trust
me okay I I I may have found something
what does it feel like to be some small
time nobody on the verge of
bankruptcy what if I don't win and I let
all all these people down you have been
trying to turn this into your own one
ring circus I got my damn life on the
line I know that
Jerry did it ever bother you the
hypocrisy the hypocrisy you sit your ass
down your
honor hey he hey wait wait what's we
can't split the pole can't split the
pole man come on
man
[Music]
a